[Musique]
et
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip nous
sommes au golf de la boulie à versailles
à mes côtés et lesquelles la chronique
au le directeur de clairefontaine alors
éric vous êtes à clairefontaine depuis
2012 mais avant de parler de votre rôle
on va parler tout d'abord de l'histoire
de clairefontaine une belle histoire qui
a commencé en 1988 directement plus de
trente ans c'était le premier centre
technique de football au monde et donc
clairefontaine depuis a connu une
histoire on va dire magnifique puisque
plusieurs équipes de france sont succédé
au sein de ces magnifiques endroits pour
permettre d'atteindre le graal de titres
de coupe du monde les champions du monde
et donc ce centre à 30 ans un peu plus
de 30 ans maintenant il a vu ses
installations se développer et grandir
s'améliorer et s'optimiser avec un
objectif à la performance sportive et
pourquoi avoir choisi cette petite
commune de clairefontaine en yvelines
moins de 2000 habitants exactement alors
c'est l'intérêt de cet endroit c'est de
pouvoir se trouver
niché au coeur d'une forêt magnifique à
l'abri des regards et donc d'avoir cette
quiétude pour les joueurs de pouvoir
s'entraîner dans un environnement
idyllique au calme et surtout à l'abri
des regards et c'est vraiment pour le
haut niveau on est d'accord à
clairefontaine or vous vous disiez
précédemment la quarantaine c'est la
maison du football donc c'est la maison
ouvert à l'ensemble du football mais
bien évidemment c'est avant tout la
maison de l'équipe de france l'équipe de
france qui vient s'entraîner plusieurs
fois par an pour préparer leurs
différents matchs internationaux lors
différentes compétitions mais y'a pas
que l'équipe de france y est aussi
l'équipe de france féminine et puis
toutes les sélections de jeunes donc
c'est un peu plus de 16 sélections
nationales qui passe sur le centre
chaque année il ya toujours du monde à à
clairefontaine effectivement nous sommes
ouverts 365 jours par an 7 jours sur 7
24 heures sur 24 donc le site est en
permanence ouvert avec un grand nombre
de délégations qui viennent sur le site
c'est un peu plus de 600 événements
c'est comme je vous le disais cette
sélection nationale c'est aussi les
arbitres de haut niveau c'est aussi pas
mal de détection de formation
l'institut de formation du football qui
permet de passer les différents diplômes
d'encadrants d'éducateurs d'entraîneur
de football ça représente + 40 semaines
par an une mille stagiaires et puis on a
aussi un rôle avec d'autres centre
médical qui est un centre médical les
belize et fifa medical center of
excellence qui est donc un label bien
particulier qui démontre de la qualité
des compétences mais aussi des
installations de ce bâtiment un centre
médical qui pas forcément que pour les
footballeurs je crois qu'il ya des
rugbymans aussi qui viennent de temps en
temps des athlètes de haut niveau
fectivement centre médical il nous
permet d'accueillir l'ensemble du monde
sportif
en particulier les footballeurs bien
évidemment c'est un peu plus d'une
centaine de joueurs professionnels qui
viennent se faire soigner chez nous mais
également nous sommes ouverts à d'autres
sports le rugby des basketteurs beaucoup
des tennismans
de même il est pilote de rallye on a
différents types de population et
comment se compose du coup le site de
clairefontaine il ya le château un peu
problématique également le centre média
il ya des terrains beaucoup de terrain
évidemment beaucoup de terrain c'est
notre raison d'être c'est dit terrain
aux dimensions officielles c'est un peu
plus de 14 terrains au total temps
hybride que synthétique naturel et puis
on va retrouver également un gymnase
pour la partie futsal les salles de
musculation un centre médical un
restaurant d'un peu plus de 180 couverts
de 100 chambres et puis bien évidemment
un espace dédié aussi à toute la part
qui presse puisque comme vous le savez
il ya une certaine caisse de résonance
médiatique à clairefontaine avec
l'accueil régulier de la presse il ya
forcément le château dont on parle à
chaque fois sur chaque rassemblement des
bleus ce château il a un peu mythique
racontez nous or le château c'est la
résidence de l'équipe de france qu'on
appelle le château alors qu'il n'est pas
le château au sens le château de la star
academy si je puis dire puisque les gens
ne viennent pas pour s'essayer les gens
sont déjà accompli qui viennent ici sont
convoqués et donc le côté mythique de ce
bâtiment c'est qu'effectivement on
accueille les joueurs de l'équipe de
france donc les 23 meilleurs joueurs en
france pratiquant du football qui
viennent pour pouvoir préparer une
compétition et donc seuls les joueurs
convoqués ont l'autorisation pénétrer
dans ce château tous les autres joueurs
donc les sélections de jeunes passent
devant regarde lorgne à travers la porte
de nos villes ne peuvent pas rentrer et
non pas cette autorisation là oui ça
donne envie et le joueur qui gravissent
les marches et qui rentre dans le
bâtiment quelque part a atteint certains
buts c'est un objectif de pouvoir
intégrer l'équipe de france et cette
équipe de france aussi chouchoutait on
peut le dire tehran l'extérieur terrain
couvert des chambres beaucoup de
chambres d
des espaces de spa de musculation
vraiment ils sont dans un confort
optimum l'objectif pour nous à
clairefontaine c'est de pouvoir
accueillir les joueurs comme à la maison
notre objectif est bien c'est une des
équipes et les gens qui m'entourent
c'est de faire en sorte que les joueurs
quand ils sont à clairefontaine n'ont
plus qu'à penser au football football
football le reste on s'en occupe donc
ils doivent effectivement bien manger
bien dormir se reposer récupérer bien
s'entraîner et tout cela remet ça passe
par diverses installations qui doivent
être au top pour pouvoir accueillir ce
qui se fait de mieux au niveau du
football en france il ya aussi le
mythique baby foot où il ya de
nombreuses parties qui s'opère alors
effectivement dans une journée dans le
château d'un joueur de l'équipe de
france il peut y avoir un certain moment
le moment où cohésion l'équipe collectif
qui sont très importants et pour cela
les joueurs aiment bien s'adonner à
quelques loisirs comme le baby foot le
ping pong par exemple et quel est votre
rôle à vous c'est d'aller voir l'équipe
de france ont justement d'être un peu
plus en retrait
mon rôle il est évidemment d'être
l'homme de l'ombre c'est à dire de faire
en sorte que l'ensemble de cette
mécanique fonctionne au mieux que
l'équipe de france mais que les
sélections nationales au sens large
puissent être accueillis dans les
meilleures conditions et donc pour cela
ça passe par beaucoup d'anticipation
pouvoir prévoir l'ensemble et mettre en
place l'ensemble des services les
installations pour pouvoir accueillir
les délégations pour qu'il n'y ait aucun
accroc aucun problème pendant leur temps
de résidence sur site aux 10 heures vous
vous êtes en place depuis 2012 à
clairefontaine est ce que vous avez vécu
des moments particuliers des moments qui
vous ont marqué mary évidemment ça fait
dix ans que que j'ai la chance au
privilège de pouvoir intervenir sur ce
magnifique site
plusieurs moments particuliers
évidemment la coupe du monde 2018 en
particulier avec cette magnifique
victoire ses préparations
l'accompagnement on va dire par de
l'équipe de france jusqu'à jusqu'à ce
titre je prendrai aussi de l'euro 2016
qui a eu lieu en france un événement
magnifique malheureusement la volée que
ça se termine différemment c'est
malheureusement le le sport c'est comme
ça mais effectivement sont des moments
qui sont ancrées qu'on ne pourra jamais
me retirer qui sont magnifiques et puis
tout un tas de projets cette évolution
du centre qui a grandit au fur et à
mesure du temps depuis maintenant 10 ans
et un lourd investissement qui a fait la
fédération pour pouvoir rénover
améliorer optimiser les installations du
site qu'est ce qui a changé justement
entre 1998 la première victoire en coupe
du monde de l'équipe de france est la
deuxième en 2018 qu'est-ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qui a changé ce que vous
sentez que le centre de clairefontaine
et plus performants maintenant qu'ils ne
l'étaient à l'époque difficile de vous
répondre parce que je n'étais pas dans
98 toutefois le site a forcément évolué
puisque le football a évolué donc il
faut pouvoir s'adapter et pour rester au
top il me faut évidemment investir il
faut régulièrement repenser améliorer
les installations on a créé un
magnifique centre liés à la partie
accueil
une publics divers et variés mais entre
autres de la presse on a créé on a
rénové nos terrains l'ensemble des
terrains du centre en passant certains
terrains en technologie qu'on appelle
hybride donc des terrains de premium de
haut niveau chauffer on avait également
investi largement dans une rénovation
des installations sportives avec la
création d'un espace de récupération un
dédié à la récupération
post entraînement post match mais
également aux échauffements étirements
en amont de
lait des entraînements voilà l'ensemble
de ces outils ont permis de développer
d'améliorer l'apparence sportive si je
comprends bien il n'y a plus d'excusé
pour perdre alors alors le football vous
savez c'est comme tout sport évidemment
il ya aussi une concurrence en face il
ya aussi d'autres belles nations qui ont
des installations au top qui ont des
joueurs au top et après c'est c'est
comme tout comme tout combat que le
meilleur gagne comme tout comme tout
sport et est-ce que vous avez une
anecdote ou plusieurs à nous raconter
sur ce centre de clairefontaine autre
que les grosses compétitions
oui je peux raconter une anecdote qui
effectivement qui va vous faire
certainement sourire puisque on a eu je
pense qu'il ya six ou sept ans de cela
une invasion
une incursion à l'intérieur du centre
alors vous me direz peut-être de
supporters un peu trop zélés ou pas du
tout qu'il s'agissait de sangliers
sangliers qui nous ont retourné une
partie d'un terrain qui était terrain
l'équipe de france d'entraînement
l'équipe de france et cela à cinq ou six
semaines de leur arrivée avant la
préparation d'une grande compétition du
coup comment réagit on peut vous dire
quand vous arrivez le matin et que vous
voyez que votre terrain est à moitié
abîmée ça vous fait pas plaisir donc il
a fallu effectivement je me rappelle
c'était un moment très compliqué et très
stressant
intervenir au plus vite pour pouvoir
remettre en état ce terrain là ce que
nous avons réussi à faire dans les temps
à 24 heures près les terrains etc
étaient prêts il ya aussi les supporters
qui viennent régulièrement voir l'équipe
de france est important aussi de les
accueillir sur ce site pour qu'ils aient
une communion entre les joueurs et
public
comme je vous disais le social du
football c'est le centre du football
alors on accueille l'équipe de france on
a que je les équipes de france on
accueille des clubs professionnels on
accueille des clubs amateurs et c'est
important de le dire c'est aussi
l'opportunité pour ces clubs là de
pouvoir venir s'entraîner sur les
terrains de clairefontaine vous de venir
passer un week end une semaine en stage
et puis on accueille aussi du public les
supporters lorsqu'il ya des
entraînements ouverts au public et puis
du public pour tout un tas d'événements
puisque le site est également ouvert
pour les séminaires d'entreprises on
accueille un certain nombre de
d'événements de séminaires tout au long
de l'année sur le site et quels sont les
gros projets pour le site dans les
années à venir il va encore évoluer ce
site de clairefontaine le site tôt en
permanence évoluer dans permanence
continuer à rester parmi
les centres les plus performants et donc
nous avons plusieurs projets un premier
projet qui consiste à créer un espace de
performance dédié uniquement à la
performance sportive avec la possibilité
dans cet espace là pour nos sélections
nationales de venir s'entraîner s'étirer
s'échauffer faire un certain nombre
d'activités physiques à l'intérieur de
ces bâtiments et ce bâtiment devrait
sortir de terre d'ici fin 2023 nous
sommes également actuellement en
cours de chantier de travaux par rapport
à une extension du centre le centre est
trop petit on manque de terrains on
manque de chambres alors malgré nos
quatorze terrains il en fallait en plus
donc nous avons des terrains
supplémentaires
nous venons créer et puis nous allons
créer une trentaine de chambres
additionnel et enfin nous allons créer
un bâtiment un centre de recherche dédié
à la recherche sportive à appliquer
directement sur nos entraîneurs ou nos
joueurs en pouvant venir y ajouter
toute la partie une nouvelle technologie
qui accompagne aujourd'hui l'évolution
notre sport et vous vous inspirez
peut-être des autres pays où vous êtes
vraiment le pays leader à votre avis où
est ce que vous allez dès fois à
l'étranger pour prendre des petites
astuces
des terrains qui sont faits d'une autre
façon peut-être il ya forcément toujours
à apprendre de ce qui se passe ailleurs
il ya beaucoup de belles choses qui sont
faites et en dehors dans le football
mais pas que dans d'autres sports aussi
on est l'occasion d'aller voir d'autres
centres sportifs
par exemple aux états unis avec des
sports comme la laine la nfl la nhl la
nba qui font aussi des choses assez
impressionnante sur la performance
sportive
mais également
pour revenir sur le football auprès
d'autres centres techniques nationaux ou
de clubs qui aujourd'hui investissent
massivement depuis un certain nombre
d'années dans l'amélioration de leurs
infrastructures sportives qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez voir à clairefontaine vous
a personnellement dans les prochaines
années
un autre titre de champion du monde et
champion d'europe de l'équipe de france
sas et pourra par rapport à l'équipe de
france mais après bien évidemment c'est
de continuer à voir grandir le centre
c'est à dire continuer à le voir
s'améliorer
et développer les installations du site
qui nécessite encore dans les années à
venir j'en suis sûr et nécessiteront de
pouvoir intégrer davantage de nouvelles
technologies au sein de cette magnifique
écrin ici nous sommes à yvelines
business club au golf de la boulie en
disant en début d'entretien vous allez
donner une conférence dans quelques
instants qu'est ce que est ce que c'est
important pour vous aussi de partager ce
qui se passe à clairefontaine et est
l'avenir de clairefontaine avec le grand
public j'ai effectivement eu cette
chance
cette opportunité de pouvoir venir
aujourd'hui m'exprimer ici et c'est pour
moi l'occasion de pouvoir présenter le
centre de pouvoir a aussi un petit peu
expliquer ce que nous faisons comment le
centre fonctionne et l'activité que nous
pouvons avoir sur sur ce site là merci
beaucoup eric lettres nico merci
beaucoup pour votre temps que vous nous
avez accordé et on espère de nouveau
titre de champion du monde pour l'équipe
de france dans les prochaines années on
l'espère merci beaucoup
[Musique]